this video is sponsored by brilliant
etymology coming from etimon meaning the
sense of truth and logia meaning study
is the study of what words really mean
or rather where words come from anyone
who has read my book firmament will tell
you that i find this subject fascinating
so in this quick video i just want to
talk about the interesting origins of a
couple of words before we start i should
point out that while we are very sure
about a lot of this much of etymology is
conjecture and there can be many
theories for why a certain word ended up
a certain way for example the english
word big may have come from a northern
english dialect or it may have come from
the old norse verb to inhabit in those
cases i'm going to go with the consensus
opinion but just note that that may be
incorrect firstly water compare how in
english we say water but in german vasa
and in swedish vaten that's because
those languages all share a common
lexical ancestor a hypothesized common
language of northwestern europe that
existed about two thousand years ago
called proto-germanic
something that linguists have pieced
together using these commonalities
between different languages
proto-germanic however is hypothesized
to have come from an older reconstructed
language that was originally spoken
around the black sea area about 6 000
years ago before migrations carried its
speakers across europe and into india
that language is
proto-indo-european and it represents
the oldest common ancestor of languages
as diverse as english urdu spanish
gujarati russian and many more water in
english comes from wator in
proto-germanic and wada in
proto-indo-european
so the word we use to refer to this has
been basically unchanged for about 6 000
years it's one of the oldest words in
the english language proto-indo-european
also sometimes allows us to drill into
the core meaning of a word like star so
this comes to english also from
proto-germanic style which originally
comes from the proto-indo-european
haiti
[Music]
i'm probably pronouncing that wrong that
word is a compound of the verb to burn
and a suffix indicating it's a noun
meaning that in the original
proto-indo-european star meant burning
or shining
thing which is kind of incredible really
because our ancestors had no way of
knowing that those pinpricks of light up
in the sky were actually well burning
things it should be noted though that
english isn't really one language it's
more like eight languages in a trench
coat it's a blend of words from all
kinds of languages from all over the
world
skull is a word that entered into the
english language around the 10th century
with the cultural exchange program
organized by the vikings
generally speaking if you find a hard k
in an english word like in skin or skill
or skirt it probably comes from old
norse skull is a particularly charming
one not so much because of the word
itself but because of what it replaced
so anglo-saxon meaning england before
the viking contact would have referred
to skin as hide and skill as craft those
words actually surviving to the present
day as some of english's many
redundancies broadly speaking if there
are multiple words for the same thing in
english they come from different lexical
roots so for example pig and swine sheep
and mutton venison and deer all
respectively come from old french via
the norman invasion and old english
skull however has unfortunately
completely replaced the far more
charming anglo-saxon word for the same
thing
brain pan
which i just think is a loss
sometimes words directly port over into
english from another language such as
for example sudoku we call those loan
words whereas we also get phrases that
are just translated word for word into a
new phrase in english for example ball
lightning which in german is kugelblitz
we call those calcs though interestingly
calc is itself a loan word from french
and loanword is a calc from the german
leinfort something that might be unique
however is anime because this is an
example of a double loan word the
english word animation was loaned into
japanese as animation which was then
shortened to anime to refer to japanese
animation which was then loaned back
into english and if anyone else can
think of any other examples of double
loan words like this please let me know
in the comments because i think that's
really cool place names often have
fascinating etymologies that reveal the
links between language and philosophy
finistere in western spain is derived
from the latin phrase finis tere
apologies to any latin scholars i just
defended by the way i went to a normal
school meaning the end of the earth it
was called this because early and
medieval christians believed there was a
connection between time and space
specifically how far east or west you
were in the east where the sun rose was
the creation of the world and in the
west where the sun set was the end of
the world and salvation thus being the
most westerly point in spain though it
actually isn't finistere was the closest
you could get on earth to the end of the
world and salvation where the walls of
heaven were as thin as a curtain
transparent as glass another place name
that's a bit more mysterious is
wolverhampton in england now england is
a mess of place names matinen did a
whole great video about this but
wolverhampton stands out its name comes
from wolfran or will thruna an
anglo-saxon woman who in the year 985
was granted a heaton a big farm or
enclosure by king ethel red the unready
this was wolf runs heaton or wolverine
hamtonia in latin which became
wolverhampton in english but where did
wolfran get her name well wolf comes
from wolf and run comes from
proto-germanic meaning secret or mystery
it's the same root actually as roon so
you have a woman who has both wolf and
mystery in her name and she has a son
whose nickname is spot
i'm not saying the city was founded by a
werewolf but i'm not not saying it and
then lastly not a word but a piece of
mathematical notation all the symbols we
use in maths have to come from somewhere
but most of the time it's pretty obvious
like the equal sign for example first
introduced in the 16th century is just
two lines of equal length this is a bit
more interesting however this is an
integration sign so when you integrate a
mathematical function like say y equals
x squared you're calculating the area
between the function and the x-axis we
say we do this by imagining bars between
the function and the x-axis and sum up
the areas of these bars the total is the
integral specifically however those bars
are infinitely thin an idea that proved
really controversial so this is a kind
of spicy summation in that infinitely
small limit so how did we end up with
this
well this is just the letter s but a
specific kind it's called a long s
you've probably seen it elsewhere in
inscriptions and in old documents when
gottfried leibniz introduced the idea of
integration as being a special kind of
sum he just described it using the
letter
looks way scarier than it actually is in
fact if you've always wanted to
understand things like calculus better
or if you'd like to brush up on your
knowledge then look no further than
brilliance course calculus in a nutshell
brilliant is a highly interactive
website and app that allows you to truly
understand topics in maths science and
computer science by guiding you through
hands-on courses rather than just giving
you a wall of information brilliant
guides you step by step through a
concept with interactive demonstrations
and exercises and if you ever feel stuck
it provides in-depth explanations to
break down the material for you even
more calculus may not be your thing
however maybe you'd like to brush up on
everyday maths like fractions or
arithmetic or learn a completely new
skill like reinforcement learning
brilliant has you covered with dozens of
professionally written courses and don't
worry if you're busy courses are
presented in bite-sized chunks allowing
you to learn at your own pace in a no
pressure environment even on your
commute if you're still doing one to get
started for free go to brilliant.org
simonclark or click the link in the
description and the first 200 of you
will get 20 off brilliant's annual
premium subscription with thanks to
brilliant for sponsoring this video
thank you so much for watching this one
i had a ton of fun making this and i
just hope you enjoyed watching as much
as i enjoyed researching and writing
this please do let me know if you'd like
more etymology content in the future you
can watch one more video right here's
some recommended ones there's even one
about etymology look if you did enjoy
this video please do pop it a like share
it with people that you think might find
this interesting and if you're not
already please do subscribe to the
channel to be notified when i make new
videos that just leaves me to say thank
you for watching i'll see you in the
next one